hello everyone how's everybody doing I
hope you're doing fine
today we're gonna continue with a
subject I began the other day and which
is extinction and what can we say
there's been a lot of ideas about
extinction for a long time this is not a
recent subject in the Bible they talk
about the forceful 4 Horsemen of the
Apocalypse you know like something like
this and these we're gonna generate or
create or trigger extinction
you got pestilence famine war and
conquest okay the four horses and you
know we've come a long ways since then I
mean these people didn't know about past
species they didn't know about the
dinosaurs not in the days of Christ and
so they came up with a little fairy
tales little stories fact they had one
before that already and that was the
what is it the 40 days and 30 nights
that it rained killed everyone according
to God except except one family that he
saved unfortunately
because supposedly we all descend from
that family Noah and his family and Noah
had tainted blood you know he he
inherited the blood from Adam who
committed original sin or primordial sin
I mean you would think that God would
have been a little smarter and started
all over again his experiment the first
one failed so let's do another one no he
kept going with that and the question is
how is God gonna kill us next time okay
he's gonna have to be a little more
creative yeah maybe not do it rain next
time anyways uh we've done better
we learned that other species
disappeared there's a little chart that
gives you a quick view of what the
establishment what the paleontologists
think about extinctions and it looks
something like this
there were many extinctions mass
extinctions throughout history of life
on Earth but there were five major ones
where a lot of species died and those
were the Ordovician the bohmian Permian
Triassic and Cretaceous one theory or
one speculation is that we are now in
the sixth mass extinction because we see
lots of animals dying around us you know
there were probably a million Lions at
the beginning of the Christian era in
the world this is an estimate just out
of nowhere but there were lots about 50
60 years ago there were only about a
hundred fifty thousand and today there's
only thirty-five thousand so something's
happening to the lion world and that's
just one example there are other animals
which are on their way out yeah we
talked about all these endangered
species that are out there some are some
even died within our you know modern era
you've got the was it the Australian
what is it the tiger what is the you got
the name but a little marsupial would
look like a fox you know like a little
wolf or whatever and he's gone he died
that I think the last one died in 1936
or there abouts anyways yeah we've had
extinctions more recently and so we
investigate those people come up with
theories
and what's interesting about the
theories we have nowadays they don't
match what people had 2,000 years ago
you know these people talked about what
pestilence war famine conquest okay and
hardly any other will show up these days
I mean here you have a notion that I put
forth the other day we have the
Cretaceous asteroid strike we have the
Permian volcanoes the Ordovician gamma
rays okay this is this is these are the
ideas we have of extinction these days
and none of these you know know the
people 2000 years ago even proposed
anything like this yeah this is all
modern so you know people don't talk
about these theories that or these ideas
that our ancestors had like 2,000 years
ago in fact here's here's a list you
know this this comes out of the
Wikipedia of what what people believe or
these really what most people believe
but what the valiant Dodgers believe or
the who knows the enthusiasts of
Futuristics whether they are this what
they think are the possible scenarios of
for the extinction of man and the first
two you see their pandemic viruses
bacteria that's pestilence right nuclear
or biological warfare that's infighting
I don't know of any species that ever
died out of infighting but this is what
they proposed simply because we have
nuclear weapons so so far we got two of
the ideas that we find in the Bible you
know with the four horsemen pestilence
and war right then you have new ones
which nobody ever thought about in the
old days climate change population
decline habitat threats those are new
then you have the catastrophes they
wouldn't have thought about that because
they didn't know about dinosaurs and so
on you have geological disasters
cosmological disasters
Suns brightness causes ocean to
evaporate okay that's gonna be in a few
billion years probably or maybe a
hundred million years I think is the
tape for that then you got the Sun
engulfing the earth that's probably
gonna kill us
seventy-eight billions years down the
road again hopefully a lot of people
think we'll be out of the solar system
by then so maybe it won't affect us okay
uncontrolled nanotechnology destroys the
Earth's ecosystems and creation about a
micro black hole under whether that one
came from they want to create a black
hole you know at CERN you know they
accelerate party go and create a black
hole absolutely right zero dimensional
thing that destroys us that's that's
better than spirits and and then you
have you know the conquest one I guess
invasion by military superior et aliens
post humans that replace us you know
they're smarter and tougher than we are
so they don't need us anymore and you
know super intelligent entity that niya
lates the human race something similar
what's conspicuously missing from the
list is famine that's the one we had
with a four horsemen while the others
are more or less representing you have
pestilence war and conquest
where's famine that's not gonna kill us
nobody even thinks of feminine of food I
mean you know you go to a supermarket
every day there's all the food you want
it's unlimited
it's how does the idiot on the shelf we
don't even know by magic you know it's
like the light that you receive or the
water you receive in your house no one
has any idea how that gets there no
nobody cares it's like oh yeah yeah I
turned the faucet on and the water comes
out and when I need food I just go to a
supermarket and there it is by magic how
it got there we have no idea who made it
who who packaged it who delivered it no
idea all we do is just go with money and
we can get buy anything we want and so
we've gotten to the point that we take
food for granted okay and so famine is
not on the list
big absence I would say the argument
here is that famine is what causes it in
other words here I get a little give
it's the third Horseman the black
horsemen and if you're wondering why
he's carrying that scale is because they
used to wait grains and bread with
scales you know it was sold by the pound
or the kilogram long time ago probably
had different measures so yeah that's
the guy that's gonna kill this it's
gonna be starvation it's the third
horseman that's what we say here okay
and of course a lot of people say you're
crazy bill I do want to put on record
you know that 99% of people do not agree
with this theory they do not subscribe
to this theory okay so if if you think
this is not right you can leave right
now you know I mean what can I do all I
can do is explain my theory to you
explain the mechanism and I'm gonna
argue for it so if you want to argue hey
bring it on let's let's see what you got
okay anyways that's what I propose
here is another vision of that it's the
overturning of the ecological pyramid we
have the many chasing the few okay a
healthy parameters that when you see on
the Left there's a ten to one ratio
between trophic levels you know you have
pretty much a ratio of ten to one from
primary production to herbivores and
there's another ten to one ratio between
herbivores and carnivores and predators
and what happens towards the end it
inverts you have the inversion of the
ecological pyramid you have the primary
production has practically disappeared
and so not only do the herbivores
you know they can't find niches in which
to
create new species but also build a
quantity of food available to them this
is lower and that goes also for you know
the Predators and carnivores etc okay
any evidence of this this could be
evidence now okay just so you know what
the separatists belong to it belongs to
religion okay anyways it's not that I
pulled it out of nowhere here here's one
example one instance in which apparently
was true and that's the Cretaceous
extinction wasn't caused by a natural
comment or meteor or whatever no it had
nothing to do with it
the plants were already being displaced
by the angiosperms which plants the own
plants the ferns and the conifers those
were being squashed out of the earth by
the newcomers the vibrant angiosperms
okay so given those firms and the
ginkgos conifers in general they were
disappeared they practically disappeared
okay basically the ones that probably
the along next eight towards the end and
there weren't too many long necks in the
Cretaceous but you also had you know
other animals such as you know the
Triceratops 'iz and well different kinds
of animals that ate all these foods when
the conifers disappear depression the
Kinko's and gymnosperms gymnosperms the
the dinosaurs the herbivores that used
to eat that you know they could
diversify and the numbers reduced and
because that happened also did the
carnivores okay so that's going to be my
notion of how extinction proceeded right
okay there are certain things that we
aren't able to do you know here I have
some things that God can't do you
God's all-powerful all-knowing and you
know God has a problem you know lifting
a stone that he can't lift this was
discovered by some philosophers in the
past okay and God can't square it a
circle or circle the square hey he's got
problems with all those kinds of things
but God has enough on his hands just
trying to exist he's fading away year by
year you know he's disappearing and
there are many things that humans can't
do and here's a summary of those things
these are some of the things that I
proposed humans are not able to do
despite their intelligence their
technology and their ability to see the
future foresight okay in advance we
can't have babies anymore okay babies
are out yeah you know women think that
they have free will
well they better think again they don't
deterministic processes make it
impossible to have babies and the main
process there is the transition from the
country to the cities that's what
happened
in the last 50 years more than that
really and in the advanced nations but
in the underdeveloped nations that
process is still going on where
everybody's moving from the country to
the cities the cities are becoming
swelled and the country is being left to
agricultural corporations which produce
the food that feeds the cities and
that's the new mode on a general scale
all over the earth when you come into
the city you can't have babies anymore
it's got nothing to do or little to do
if anything with NGOs you know these
non-government organizations I go there
and coach women not to have babies to
have fewer babies or whatever you know
that secondary though
main problem areas or the main culprit
for why we're not having babies is the
transition from the country to the city
can't have ten babies in an apartment
period okay
you can't eliminate the wealth pyramid
we're always gonna have rich
middle-class poor there's gonna be that
pyramid and nothing will change that now
a lot of people you know I was a
communist for many years I thought we
can change that I learned the hard way
you know it's not gonna change and you
know there were revolutions you had
Lenin's revolution uh in 1917 and even
before that you had the French
Revolution where they killed the Kings a
hundred years earlier you know and what
happened well a new class of people came
in there they became too rich they
became the new Kings that's all that oh
that's all that happens so revolution
only brings new people the power that's
all it does it doesn't change the
overall structure even in so-called
communist countries like Cuba and North
Korea you have the pyramid guy at the
top he's got a limousine the guy at the
bottom he barely has enough to eat
that's everywhere no no one on the
planet no country on the planet lives
any differently okay increasing genetic
diversity we have no way of doing that
some people think in fact there are some
the other day there was an article about
a Chinese who who's been tailoring or
tinkering with genetic you know trying
to change the genetics of babies you
know some people say it's you know
unethical to do that well that's another
story right but the issue is can we do
it is it physically possible and I I
don't see any possibility of that what
they're trying to do is create genetics
in such a way that it can withstand
diseases that's a primary focus of that
process I'm not even sure the goal is is
right because we don't die of diseases
these days what we die is of old age you
know the age of diseases has gone by so
even if we did but I don't even think
it's
genetic diversity will continue to
disappear in the human race we already
have very little genetic diversity
iversity were all clones of each other
if you take the DNA of your DNA compared
against just about any other person on
earth we're all the same pretty much
very little difference between us 8
billion people very little difference we
had a boy growing old we can't avoid
dying individually right we can't do
anything about overturning the
population pyramid which has been
overturning since 1963 last time we have
2.3 growth rate on global this is for
the whole world today it stands at 1 and
by mid-century it's going to be at 0 ok
we're gonna and someone clarified that
that doesn't mean we're not gonna have
babies no you're right and I I guess I
misspoke last time I want to clarify
that I'm not saying we're not gonna have
babies I'm saying you know one person is
born one person dies so the population
stays stable at least for a few minutes
I think it's gonna drop after that it's
never going to go up it's never going to
stay stable it's gonna go down and
that's if we ever reach 2050 I doubt
that very much anyways we can't have
travel to the past to the future that's
relativistic nonsense travel to the
nearest star impossible no no way we can
do that colonize Mars I don't think it's
ever going to happen yeah if we had a
million years maybe could terraform Mars
and play around with the atmosphere and
the pressure and the gravity you know
but again you know Mars is a smaller
planet not half but close to half the
volume of of the earth and even if we
could terraform and fill it with water
and have breathing air we would have the
problem with gravity because being a
smaller planet it would hold less air
therefore the pressure at sea level
would be different ok would be not as as
as strong as it is here
how long it would take calculations
based on trend technology stand anywhere
between a hundred thousand and two
hundred thousand years
can we improve on that with some kind of
advanced technology
well even assuming we could I cannot
imagine so we're gonna happen colonizing
Mars like Carl Sagan dreamed of you know
and contacting the Klingons and so on
it's never gonna happen
we're dead we're on the last stretch now
so well again some people will have
these dreams they watch a lot of
Hollywood movies that's where they get
their education they believe all this is
possible okay I can't do anything about
you believe what you want yeah
extinction of the human race we cannot
avoid it all species are born to die
there is not one species that survived
some people believe there are species
that live forever you know they have
these Lazarus species and there's a big
issue there you know it's just what can
I say plain ignorance and that comes
from paleontologist certified guys you
know so go trust them anyway it's a
recapping what I did last week just just
so last time extinction 101
you're gonna put comments start by
telling the crowd how passed species
disappeared don't start with man
everybody loves to talk about
everybody's an expert on man on humans
we all know how they're gonna die over
how they're not going to die and
everybody knows that everybody's got an
opinion nobody's got a mechanism because
so far I haven't seen any mechanism but
it'd be nice if you can show that you're
an expert at extinction before you show
your expertise in the extinction of man
okay and that I call extinction 100
extinction of man we'll call that
extinction 102 okay you can't get to 102
until you did the prerequisite okay so
you must explain past extinction
I argued that food chain was included
all extinction theories therefore it's
the common denominator it's what I call
the cookie cutter okay we can apply it
to any age any habitat we can apply to
any climate and it also explains
selectivity you can explain through the
food chain why one food chain
disappeared why one remains alive and
you can also explain with this mechanism
why what disappeared was always in every
case 100% of the cases
okay the old species disappeared the new
species the ones that mother nature
spawned relatively recently those were
the ones that continued the mammals came
after the dinosaurs with disappeared
with the dinosaurs the dinosaurs came
after the arcus ours the Argus ours were
we're born or were spawned before the
dinosaurs were spawned the synapses came
before the arcus ours they respond by
mother nature before the orcas ours
isn't there a pattern there that you see
you know it's like it's always the old
species that died and the new ones that
continue well the only reason for that
is food when the plant disappears the
one the old specie got used to after
millions of years all these all these
species diversify and they each one got
their own niches and their climates and
different plants and whatever they ate
and when that whole ecosystem
you know disappeared so did the animals
that were that forged a long term
relationship with them
why did the other animals die because
they were small at the time they were
growing together with a new vegetation
and as far as they were concerned they
were not even part of the other food
chain so we're talking about different
food chains same in the water you know
me and the Seas what
had his different food chains when one
food chain disappeared like in the case
of the Moses are at the end of the
cretaceous
you know they disappeared that didn't
affect the fish at all because there
were two different worlds
the Moses ours a a lot of ammonites it
turns out the ammonites disappeared what
did the ammonites eat they ate the
foraminifera and those disappeared which
by the way they were all Giants the the
foraminifera were giants as as well as
the manna plankton they were big
monsters compared to what came after
the ammonites they disappeared why they
were big Moses are they disappear why
because they were big all the big guys
disappeared and the little guys stayed
behind in general this is a general term
but you'll always find out what
disappears at the end of a mass
extinction is always always big bait
nests represents that this animal not
only was king of the planet at the time
or rude his nieces etc but he forged a
long term relationship with the plants
and was able to grow according to what
is known as coax law the fact that
animals over time grow bigger and bigger
and bigger we are bigger you know you've
seen the little picture of a little
monkey and a bigger bigger bigger until
it comes to man right
and that's what it was we're bigger than
what our ancestors were in general terms
okay so you got a look at these things
clear X was big he was the guy who died
at the end and he wasn't made big from
the start he grew to that big size over
billions of years
anyways plants undergo cycles they have
their plants have this overturning of
their population pyramid they have their
loss of genetic diversity after millions
of years they will die no matter what
today we're helping that process you
know people don't like to eat grapes
with seeds so they see
those grapes and so what do our farmers
do well they you know they clone these
plants I don't know if you've seen how
grapes are grown today but you know they
just take a piece of another plan they
planned and they have a new plant so
it's all cloning all clone all that
stuff is clone we do that with horses we
do that with cows also you know you know
that any bull just mount up cow or any
you know horse like a racehorse you
don't let anyone
he's got to be the winner he's got to be
the star that's the kind of semen you
want inside that that female okay and so
the other guys I don't know they have to
masturbate or something over there you
know and man cannot avoid the same
process man cannot avoid running into
starvation and the main reason for that
is that we grow food for an abstraction
we call money
and my argument is gonna be that it is
money which is going to be which is
going to disappear we have this
abstraction and our very lives that
depends on this abstraction and yet
people will have trouble believing that
you know that it's food that's gonna
disappear because no one will produce it
or distribute it to the cities why
because money has disappeared because no
one will accept money at some point
either because it devalued completely or
because we all lost our jobs or most of
us lost our jobs and the only purpose of
money is to pay salaries that's that's
essentially it
okay in a nutshell and I'll go over more
detail probably next week on this but
here we have the proposal anyone who
wants to put a comment needs to put a
deal with extinction 101 first if you
can't put anything about the past
animals you know nothing about
extinction much less can you know about
human extinction and people don't like
that people say no no I want to talk
about human see I'm an expert only in
human extinction but they don't know how
any of the past animals died no one
no one I'd receive no comments on past
extinctions no one came up with a
mechanism saying let me tell you how the
dinosaur died either synapsis died or
how the orcas are no one not one person
but everybody I mean I had a lot of
people put comments for all over the
place
everybody's an expert on human
extinction we know exactly how humans
are gonna die or how they aren't gonna
die okay how they're gonna avoid
extinction right but we don't know
anything about extinction and that's
suspicious
okay once you did that well then you
gotta tell me how humans will if humans
will ever die I mean are we gonna good
forever
some people believe we're gonna live
forever others say no but they can't
come up with a foolproof mechanism I
mean if you can't come up with a
foolproof mechanism you cannot say that
we will die that we will become extinct
you have to believe like the other guys
that we would look forever because you
don't have a mechanism okay
so again those are the questions you got
to answer will humans ever die and if so
okay if we will die you got to have a
foolproof mechanism for extinction and
if you say that we won't die you're not
off the hook you still have to come up
and say how we will avoid extinction
especially if you can tell us first you
know extinction 101 how the animals in
the past die because if you don't know
how the animals in the past died and you
say well I don't know that I don't care
because it's irrelevant well then you
know and then you can't tell and then
you say well and we won't become extinct
well then you you eluded the question
that's what you did you weren't able to
tell them that the crowd the audience
they're how the animals in the past
disappear and you cannot project that
onto man you just have an opinion that's
all you have you don't have a mechanism
of avoidance or extinction
okay so let me get to the comments and
again none of them addressed extinction
101 okay
so we'll just have to go whatever we
have there and here's one of the
comments he came up so if you had an
argument wanting to tear it to pieces
before you even hear the argument then
you have no intention of finding truth
it only proves that you're too steeped
in your own superstitions to consider
truth love it okay so how do I reply to
that well here here it is first one is
that you know anyone who talks about
truth or proof is talking about religion
he's a religious fanatic we don't use
the word truth in science we don't use
the word proof in science it's only
religious fanatics who use those words
and you know proof is in the pudding it
in alcohol as far as we're concerned
religious individual attempts to talk
about evidence because he's trying to
prove to the jury Scientists does
something different scientists explains
a mechanism so that you understand you
reach your own conclusion in your own
dark basement later on that's the way
science should be run science has
nothing to do with proving or true thing
or whatever this individual talked about
and of course he's one of these
religious individuals who wants the
cheat he wants to skip extinction 101
because he knows nothing about
extinction and he says well you know
you're trying to defeat my argument from
the start I'm not I want you to tell me
something about extinction before you
tell me about human extinction if that's
too heavy a burden for you well maybe
you got to check your your theory and
again you know science doesn't want to
listen to opinions science wants to
listen to make any explosions of
mechanisms okay here's another comment
okay and I think it was a woman cities
need to be undone I know I think it's
about this and this individual says that
we're destroying the environment
well I can say first of all we cannot
undo cities you know we don't we're not
gonna go back in time we're not going to
go back to agriculture we're not gonna
go back to hunter gathering and we're
not gonna go to manufacturing back again
we're stuck with services and from there
we can only move forward and forward
means to unemployment we are now in the
unemployment phase which I believe is
the last phase in human economy and more
and more people will become unemployed
in the coming months and in the coming
years whatever time we have and until at
some point there's gonna be a breaking
point where there's too many people
unemployed collecting you know some kind
of insurance Social Security whatever
there's got to be a retired essentially
in life that they're going to be 20
year-olds living off the government in
other words off the people who work who
pay their taxes and those taxes go to
you know to welfare unemployment or
whatever so I think what's going to
happen you're gonna have more and more
unemployment because we are gonna be
kicking people out of manufacturing for
one we're becoming more efficient with
that and they're gonna be moved all
those people will be moving like we did
in the past from agriculture to
manufacturing
now we're gonna be moving all these
people from both agricultural whatever's
left there's very little in agriculture
in both countries but we're gonna be
moving or manufacturing to services and
once you're in services well you have
you have a fake economy services of a BS
economy most of it at based insurance
that's a promise
banking that's a promise all these are
promises credit cards etc all those are
promises something to happen in the
future and we rely on those for faith on
faith you know it's just faith that
keeps that going nothing but faith and
you know when you come to think of it
everything humans produce everything we
produce the only purpose of it the only
purpose of money of richness of wealth
is to exchange it for food see it only
allows us to live one more day see Bill
Gates he can have 10 TV sets he can have
I don't know how many cars how many
houses but he cannot eat all more than a
certain amount and likewise he can have
zero pet rocks and for those of you who
don't know what a pet rock is and I
think it was in the 70s 80s or 90s they
had this guy came up with the idea that
instead of having a dog at home that you
feed it moves around wagging his tail
you had this rock inside of some kind of
enclosure and and you and you talk to it
you know yeah you water in whatever okay
and so the guy sold pet rocks and he
made some money with that and you know
you can live with zero pet products you
don't need those you can't live with
zero food so you can't live with zero
food and you can't eat gazillions of
tons of food no matter how rich you are
okay so food is one of those Goldilocks
type of commodity where it has to be
just right for the population of Earth
you produce all the cell phones you want
you can produce fewer cars more cars
that doesn't matter for it has to be
just right yeah and people don't always
understand the importance of food we
think we're not animals that's that's
the real issue people we've become so
arrogant as humans that we don't even
pay attention to food anymore and when
you look at it all animals all animals
the only thing they pay attention to is
food you know think about that for a
second you know perceive those wild
animals all day that's all that's on
their mind is food your stomach that's
all that's under mine they don't think
about cell phones they don't think about
anything except food and we've forgotten
our animal roots that's what it is
anyways we're not going to go back to to
the past we're not going to go back to
hunter-gathering we're not going to go
back to our culture we're not going to
go back to manufacturing those stages
are
economic development are over and now
what we have is service economy in
advanced countries like the United
States and European countries Japan not
so much yet China but all these
countries at least the advanced
countries have a lot of the
underdeveloped countries in fact they
have like 85% of their economy their GDP
gross domestic product you know is
services and services of bs economy it's
it's an abstraction there's no there's
no such thing as services but the rest
even our eco caps the anarcho-capitalist
they talk about value value so they have
this abstraction they think Mickey Mouse
is for real Donald Duck they have this
Disneyland economy this is a notion of
economy that's what they were taught
this is what they repeating is what they
believe in and well I can only smoke and
laugh what can I say you know the real
economy is the food economy and if you
want to add something to that
manufacturing don't add services which
is 85 percent of our economy and it's
all abstraction there's nothing there
the day the Martians come and find us
all dead they will find the food that we
may have left behind maybe the the
fields you know with some plants there
they'll find the highways they'll find
the houses they'll find the cars they'll
find their cell phones they will not
find a single service services disappear
overnight
yeah anyway so this is my answer to that
extinction is guaranteed hey humans
cannot avoid extinction Illuminati some
people talk about those the New World
Order
nonsense got nothing to do with it the
rich people can't avoid it either in
fact when the caca hits the fan okay the
rich people won't be able to escape this
what's coming they won't be
pay their employees with anything except
food food will be the only thing of
value at that point and the slave the
for the worker whatever you want to call
the proletarian he will have no reason
to have allegiance to the rich man
anymore so this notion that you know the
rich are going to corral humans into pig
pens or whatever
chicken poos it's just too much
Hollywood movies that's what it is
that's where these people get their
education politicians economists
preachers priests civic leaders they
can't do anything about extinction
either extinction is guaranteed it was
programmed into our species just like in
any other species from the moment
mother nature spawned us okay and you
know she she programs it into us species
die alone in a background extinction and
dying mass in a die with other similar
species like in in this case got me all
the mammals we die all together all his
good buddies okay and you're here you
have Mother Nature spawning man and
other animals and when she spawns him
she's already programming extinction in
these new species that she puts out okay
okay so here's another comment gay
person asked when is it going to happen
and also says whether we turn it into a
background extinction background
extinction is different than a mass
extinction it's like you know some
people say well why do we have to have a
single mechanism of extinction why can't
we have ten different mechanisms of
extinction so we do the Cretaceous will
with an asteroid how's that for an idea
and then we go to Permian well we can do
that one with volcanoes how's that and
your division will do it with a SAP
gamma-ray from a supernova well that's
like saying that mother nature does
gravity in ten different ways she does
grab the over here she does it with
particles and over there you know near
the black hole she does it with gravity
waves and then over there she does it
with warp space and when she sees bill
gate he well she does it with ropes so
she's got all these different mechanisms
for gravity no just like she does
gravity in one way in one way only
whichever way that is like why she does
extinction with only one way one way
only mass extinction now you might say
well background extinction like this
lady put here background extinction is
different but that's like comparing
magnetism versus gravity you know
magnetism is not the same process as
gravity we're all literacy is not the
same process as gravity and so the
background extinction is to a mass
extinction light magnetism is to gravity
they're not they have different
mechanisms okay
species dies all alone when it becomes
old on the own species and what is an
old species as a species that first lost
its genetic diversity and its population
pyramid overturned in other words they
became older and no more of the
population became ever more older and
there were fewer and fewer new children
which is what's happening to us by the
way fortunately for us we're never going
to see that because a mass extinction is
going to take place before a background
extinction okay so now it's not going to
happen through a background extinction
the last of the species like the t-rex
long line of diner from dynasty dies at
a mass extinction not in a background
extinction and we are the last of the
whole minute
it's hominins hominins and the last ones
die in a mass extinction when they're
the rulers of the planet where the
rulers okay so that's the point so yeah
we're gonna die in a mass extinction
we're not gonna die in a background
extinction we're not gonna die of old
age we're not gonna die because our DNA
depleted or we lost our genetic
diversity we're losing it yes but we're
not going to make it there we're not
gonna die because of that we're gonna
die because our economy collapses way
before we lose our genetic diversity
completely okay like the Neanderthals
lost it so so yeah she says when is it
going to happen
well her guess is as good as mine I mean
you know I'm allowed some people say I'm
a lousy scientist too but I'm a lousy
astrologer so I can't tell you when I
can't tell you the first of May of the
year 2030 no way no one can tell you
that not even God okay so we don't know
when all I can do is give you this
history of modes of production part of
this comes from Marxist Leninist versus
Marx and Engels ideology okay but it's
they did research specially marketed
research at the library of London for
many years and I think he had a good
grip on this issue so I like to use his
notion and look something like this
we had hunter-gathering for over a
hundred thousand years probably two
hundred thousand years after that we
discovered farming around the Neolithic
era plus or minus ten not - but about
ten thousand years ago maybe 12,000 okay
there is there's different estimates
about and so farming displaced
hunter-gatherer we started doing less
and less hunter-gathering and we moved
into farming and farming eventually
became commercial we went from
subsistence to commercial farming for
first time we invented trade something
lots of people today have serious
problems understanding everybody thinks
we had trade in the days of the
nano-cells
in the days of the upper Palaeolithic no
such monster we invent were the only
animal that trades you know typically
hyenas don't trade with cheetahs for
example they kind of steal but they
don't trade and we never traded there
was no such thing as trading because the
the guy who went to trade traded his
life that's what he traded you don't
trust anyone in the jungle there's no
911 and so we went from hunter gathering
into farming and at some point we
invented discovered or whatever trade
commerce and for that first time we
started trading and became specialized
in what we did some people did farming
some people did I don't caught the three
others did blacksmithing and so on and
eventually about 300 years ago
manufacturing started pushing aside
farming we became more efficient in our
farms and people started leaving the
farms and going into the cities and
working in manufacturing in industry and
this past century 20th century
officially after World War Two in fact
during World War Two especially that's
what suppose he got us out of the mess
out of the unemployment and because of
World War two and what came after we
started going into services and what was
left behind was manufacturing and
agriculture practically disappeared
today it's in an advanced country like
the United States it goes anywhere from
one to two percent and that's including
forestry and other stuff that they
include under what is known as
agriculture not only is labor 1 to 2
percent but so but agriculture is also
about 1 to 2 percent of GDP on the other
hand manufacturing is still maybe
anywhere between 10 and 50 percent and
services which is the nonce
economy and he went through those
services is out of a job essentially he
has no job that's eighty five percent of
the people okay and so what's next is
true unemployment where you know you do
whatever you do but you don't get any
money you have the only way to get money
is from the government because there is
no job out there for you to do because
every niche is taking over and yeah
people say bill you're crazy you don't
know anything about economics okay it's
just what people believe and yeah it's
incredible but it's very hard to get
some of these points true ok so here's
another comment so it's on the imminent
extinction of man you're right you are
right for all the wrong reasons
ok let's see we are heading towards
extinction because of genetic
engineering so so we're engineering
ourselves out of our bodies or something
right we're gonna become androids or
whatever we will be going the way of
cro-magnon Magnum chrome on young man
genetically surpass surpassed eventually
by the next human hybrid this guy
believes the chrome on y'all disappeared
because somehow he lost his genetic
diversity and that's nonsense
just pure ignorance and so he believes
the same thing that somehow we're gonna
be genetic we're going to do some
genetic engineering on our bodies and
we're gonna disappear as a consequence
of that as far as you know the animals
in the past we're concerned mass
extinctions they never disappeared
because of genetic engineering and
that's why it's important to do
extinction 101 you got to tell me how
the animals in the past disappeared
because we're going to disappear in the
same way because Mother Nature doesn't
do extinction in ten different ways and
that's what people can't go through
their thick skulls
there's only one mechanism for mass
extinction one and one only and that's
why you gotta show me what how how the
animals disappeared in the past you
gotta have an extinction Theory
otherwise you can't talk about
extinction don't tell me what's going to
happen to man if you if you don't know
what happened to the animals you don't
have a theory
you have nothing bill to provide you you
don't have a mechanism you have nothing
to share all you have is your opinion
and your opinion is worth as much as
this guy's I mean you know what does he
know about extinction of the animals
nothing and so he believes there will be
hybrids 3,000 years from now maybe maybe
not yeah whatever I mean this is the
type of comment I get I get comments of
people who just want to tell you their
their beliefs and you don't have any
meat in there there's no mechanism to
share people don't share mechanism
because they don't have the brains to
create mechanisms they do not put any
any any grey matter into it they just
read and they watch a movie and they
said I know humans are gonna die this
way or that way they just get an opinion
they they they never look into these
things they never do research okay and
that's that's very frustrating because
it's like talking to a wall here are the
typical arguments that people usually
raised and says we've had a Kannamma
crisis in the past they didn't cause
extinction this is one argument always
thrown against me man has intelligence
technology foresight he can solve any
problem people have this notion that man
can solve anything any problem that
comes his way because he's got
intelligence and yet you know God can
look the stone that he can't live you
know so you must want become extinct we
will evolve will colonize the Stars
people have these dreams of going
somewhere out into space we can't even
get to the moon barely to the moon you
know I mean you know then they don't
want to do it with humans anymore
because it's too costly
okay Insurance alone is exorbitant
humans will become extinct but not
through either
comics will nuke each other never has
been
no no animal in the past died from
infighting horses never killed horses to
the to the last horse or anything like
that
yeah disease never killed any species
disease never kill the species always
someone survives no matter what disease
no matter how violent it is okay ET
catastrophe never happened okay not a
single species died because of asteroid
or what K knows or or what gamma-rays
absolutely ridiculous and the main point
there is that they cannot explain
selectivity and they never will and so
they have to invent one mechanism for
each species for each habitat how did
the animals in underwater will die well
the acidity you know the other we had
some acid rain and how did the other
guys that well that was heat and fire
and the other and I know they were
drowned you know the water slutted to
Lance so they have to have one mechanism
per species per habitat and Mother
Nature doesn't work that way because
then it means that they're relying a
whole bunch of on a whole bunch of
coincidence says you know a bunch of
processes just happening at the same
time distinct processes so they have to
do this because they can't play explain
the only thing in the extinction theory
has to explain which is selectivity and
with food you can explain that very
easily it's in fact it's the only one
that can explain it okay and there can't
be a total you get on the class because
as the Nariko caps capitalists say you
know we'll continue trading all they can
say is trade trade day they never can
get away from trade they think
everything's trade and you can't get the
word trade out of their mouth because
that's what they've been brainwashed
with they can only use the word trade
will be trading and trading and trading
forever for the next million years my
god what can I say and you can't get
them the reason that trade is dead there
won't be any trade in the future
you know when when when the whole
economy collapses you're not gonna be
trading your cellphone for a banana okay
the guy who's got a banana he's got he's
gonna live a little longer than you
because he's got something to eat and
you have nothing day so you will not be
trading anything so those people who
think they're gonna be trading with
their neighbor you know you come with
with your cellphone to trade and he
comes with a gun and tastes takes it
away from you maybe it's just that
simple
there's no 9-1-1 when when the whole
thing collapses if people don't
understand it so it's just unbelievable
I said I just can't believe how people
reason or don't now there won't be any
trade anyone talking about trade has to
go see a psychiatrist okay so yeah and
so here's the humor at the end we have
the comedy hour we have an individual
who says he's been 20 years researching
extinctions just like Bill well I don't
think so because this guy could not come
up with a single mechanism he hasn't
said anything in fact you'll see it here
starting at the human extinction level
in other words 102 and not extinction
level 101 is irrelevant okay I would go
so far using Bill's own words that
anyone making dinosaur extinction the
human extinction is an ignoramus okay
but see he hasn't justified it that's a
statement
he hasn't justified I justified it
that's the difference okay I said why
it's gonna happen that way because first
we can only have one mechanism of
extinction and that mechanism is food
why is it food I showed graphs first and
second it's the only one to explain
selectivity so I have a reason for
proposing food okay this guy as you'll
see he has no no idea whatsoever animals
plants bacteria over the last billion
years have barely been able to change
their environment to the same as human
as as humans so so what well what does
that have to do with extinction
we're words that are the
action animals look to simply procreate
and pass on their genes well I thought
he was talking about humans I mean what
do we look for just to appropriate and
pass on our genes I guess right humans
are the only animal species over see he
said animals and humans now he says
we're an animal at least he recognizes
that that we belong to the animal world
certainly we're not rocks and minerals
were not plants I guess we're animals
right humans are the only animal species
that can control and we will become
significantly better at this in the
future their environment we are the only
species that has gone to space on
purpose so what is that what what does
any of that have to do with extinction
where is the connection to extinction
okay so the fact that he mentions that
you know it's just again it's spinning
his wheels here's here's another comment
by that same individual and says he
gives me a link i go to that link and he
says it summarises the link says even
Bill's favorite theory of food shortage
is there so he really should denigrate
the scientist who endless whose endless
hours a word the simple statements
summarized and he says a rational model
of extinction that is consistent with
the food pyramid well I'm not really
first of all I mentioned already that
all extinction theories talk about the
food chain I've already said that this
guy wasn't listening or something I
don't know so he didn't didn't catch
that and so but anyways when you go to
this site that he puts in there and it
just shows you how these people think
okay now the majority of people think so
this what you find in that site says
many theories have been suggested for
the extinction of dinosaurs aha some of
these have dealt with toxic volcano into
volcanic gases and dust asteroid impact
food shortage mentions food shortage
climate change okay what do you find in
the entire site about food shortage just
this statement this is all you'll find
perhaps a dramatic change interrupted by
the weather patterns or destroyed the
food of the dinosaur
factors that could cause a sudden change
would be what asteroid meteor a
meteorite
comet so so what this fella missed and
what most people miss is the why what
caused the plants to disappear the food
to disappear it just went from one ear
to the other because there was nothing
to stop it in between this guy's head
that's why he said that he is rambling
you nonsense because he doesn't
understand what I said okay so he's
putting words in my mouth and what can I
say you know this it's one of the big
poems I have people not understanding
the theory because they don't even stop
in and long enough to understand it they
just see it superficially continue so
what else does this individual saying
here he shows you know how much he
understood or the theory he says and
remember this guy says he studied twenty
years or a research or is interested for
twenty years of the subject matter birth
the birth rate is declining so his death
rate bill the average global birth rate
was eighteen point five blah blah blah
in 2016 the death rate was lalala net
equal ten point seven population
increased well we know the population is
increasing
he missed the point altogether in there
for a guy who supposedly looked at this
for 20 years you wonder how he missed
this this is the chart that shows that
towards the middle of our of this
century popular populations gonna level
off in other we will not continue to
increase why because the birth rate is
declining middle by little and even and
the birth rate is is still increasing
now but not after in the hump
after the hump birth the death rate will
not overcome the the birth rate in other
words it's it's only after we let me
show this other graph which will put it
in the right perspective which is
similar you know you'll find these
graphs all over the internet okay
we go from convex to concave in other
words sorts them towards the middle of
the century it's going to level off okay
that's what's going to happen no matter
what and what's gonna happen after that
then birth are gonna go down drastically
and death rates are gonna follow right
behind because the old people will start
dying okay so both will go down but the
birth rate will go down much faster
because essentially no one will have
children that's why so so the birth rate
is gonna go negative in other words the
Ruby children born but one every you
know be like Halley's Comet once every
75 years or whatever should be a very
rare occurrence and the last one shows
you know for a total comedy it shows
what this guy understood here okay see
if I can put myself in there he says so
what is Bill saying let's see what am I
saying let's see what he understood my
interpretation and how it actually is
similar to what many scientists are
saying owes and so I'm saying the same
thing as all other scientists I'm saying
what I'm saying I'm the first guy ever
to say it in the last 10,000 years this
guy says I'm saying the same thing as
all everybody else so so some something
one of us who has to be wrong for sure
okay so what is this guy saying he's
saying that this is what I say he says
that I'm saying meteor volcano some
external factor causes a dramatic
climate change event absolutely not no
external factor no climate change only
only this girl the Norwegian girl she's
the only one who talks about climate
change rational people don't talk about
climate change because not because it's
not happening but because it has nothing
to do with nothing with extinction with
nothing so don't worry ever again about
climate change you'll never see anything
related to climate change that's only
for politics okay so this fellas brain
was so much with climate change so he
thinks that somehow this external factor
will will cause as he says next some
kind of sign that the disappearance of
plants so he said this affects plant
photosynthesis
never did I mention photosynthesis so
where he got this I don't know he's
putting words in my mouth some plants
start dying out other plants take over
some herbivores start dying out
this leads absolutely none okay this I
don't say this but this is what these
are the words he's putting in my mouth
this leads to some predators dying out
it just so happens that this that the
some in this case were the dinosaurs
because they were the least able to
adapt never did I talk about adaptation
I really gainst adaptation
photosynthesis external factor climate
change
yeah I I argue completely against each
one of those issues that this guy is
raising so obviously he didn't
understand squat and I'm wondering how
many other people out there have the
same notion I mean I keep telling people
that you know that these things have
nothing to do with extinction they he
bring you on back like you know this is
what I said so I don't know what their
understanding and if the number of
predators reaches a minimum number they
will eventually become extinct
absolutely not that's not what I say Oh
none of this is what I say at all and
and so this was really more comedy yeah
I'm saying you know how could he
misunderstand everything he didn't catch
one and of course in none of his
writings did he propose an AEA an
extinction of the animals in fact in one
of the comments he I may have missed it
here he mentions that he doesn't know
about what processes the experts or what
mechanisms the experts propose for the
extinction of some of the animals in the
past he says that he says he's been
researching for twenty years but he says
he doesn't understand what mechanisms
caused the extinction of course he
doesn't that's why he wants to skip over
extinction 101 that's why he says it's
irrelevant to us humans because what we
will never become extinct that's what he
says well you know I mean a lot of
people think like him they think that we
won't become extinct ever again that's
up to each individual to decide
himself I think not only we will become
extinct but very soon extremely soon and
why because our economy can't can't
sustain for much longer you know and
that's the reason I think you know we
don't have too much time to go but again
that's a gut feeling listen s you know
how soon will it happen how much time do
we have and I can give you a rule of
thumb to work on in your mind for your
own enjoyment if you have nothing to do
it goes something like this if all the
heads of state today
you know you get Myrtle you get Trump
you get Johnson Chinese guy poutine
South American guy African guy you know
the heads of state in one place okay
listen to us and they all work towards
the destruction of the economy they put
their heads together how can we destroy
the economy on purpose let's commit
suicide how fast can we do it sometimes
you think that that's rightfully Dewey
let's say they put their heads together
to try to destroy the world through the
economy well that can happen as quick as
today so you know that the starting
point it would take a few weeks for all
of us to die but they could they could
screw up the economy so badly if they
put their heads together they work on it
hard enough and they have all these
other people working with them they can
destroy the economy today and you know
we would be dead within maybe one or two
years all of us so that's so now you
have your minimum scenario that's the
fastest that's how fast we can go
extinct now what's the maximum well the
maximum is what if we did everything
right run our economy perfectly well
from here on down using computers
whatever you know whatever we we have
the eyes of God the knowledge of God and
this is what we implement on earth we
implement a perfect system whatever that
system is and let's say that we're
allow us to live 50 years 50 more years
well that would never happen it would
never happen because the way humans work
is that intelligence is trumped by by
interest interest Trump's intelligence
you know for example what if the
solution were communism just to give an
example and the rich would say well no I
don't like communist I'm gonna pose it
and a guy does everything possible to
avoid going into communism and you have
all these rich people moving their money
around whatever their tastes because
they want to preserve their privileges
so even though intelligence says this is
what we should do whatever it is I'm
just giving you communism as an example
interest will go against that and so we
never get the best of that intelligence
can give us we always get less than that
because of interest personal interest so
those are the rule of thumbs that you
can use together to apply to whatever
notion of extinction that you have for
humans all I can tell you is you know it
we will die because of food because
that's the mechanism mother nature used
in the past she uses it with all species
and we are a species we are an animal
people don't believe that but we
unfortunately we are animals we Pope we
eat we sleep just like any other animal
and I know this is news to you but yeah
we belong to the animal world and you
know we don't care and you know Mother
Nature doesn't care about our cell
phones or cars or airplanes she only
makes sure that we care about food food
keeps us alive three four or five days
together with air and water of course
right the vitals and that's what kills
those killed for sure and the other
thing that kills is obviously aging
which is a function of gravity and the
other thing is you know disease and so
on but you know disease
ever killed the single species so it's
going to be food and why food because
it's run under our artificial economy
and our artificial economy cannot grow
forever and there's a famous saying grow
or die we will die ok we'll see you next
time
look at some of the questions that
people put up there and we'll see if we
can address them the following what is
it Sunday so we'll see you then
bye bye